It is my real pleasure to
introduce Eliott Cheu, who
will be the speaker today.
Elliott has a first
class pedigree.
He comes from Stanford
and Cornell and Chicago.
He came here when the
University of Arizona
was sort of leading a
charge to try to create--
be part of a collider that
was going to take over
an enormous area in Texas.
It was killed by the government
because it was too expensive.
And from there,
somehow or another,
we ended up with the
Large Hadron Collider,
which is in Switzerland,
which is what we're going
to be talking about today.
Elliott is part of the group
at the University of Arizona
that has been part of
one of the detectors
that famously measured
the Higgs boson--
again, one of these
incredible things that's
been happening
lately in physics.
That was a few years back.
Elliott bet on the wrong
horse at that point.
He was betting on a thing
called supersymmetry.
So then he decided to quit that.
I'm just kidding.
So Elliott has gone from his
interest in supersymmetry
to dark matter.
And I think everybody
here has already
heard it one way or
another, that the universe
is composed mostly of dark
matter and dark energy.
We don't really know what any
of these things are about.
And Elliott has
been working hard
at trying to figure out what
dark matter is all about.
But Elliott is one of these
sort of multiple threat
kind of guys.
Elliott was my associate dean
in the College of Science.
So if you ever go to
the Tucson book festival
and you talk about
the science city,
it was Elliott that got
all that stuff going.
When you talk about
science cafes,
Elliott's fingerprints
are all over that.
When you talk about many of
our undergraduate students
in the College of Science--
about 70% of them--
being involved in undergraduate
research education--
in other words, they're stuck
in a lab somewhere doing some
fantastic research--
Elliott's fingerprints
are all over that.
Elliott just took over being
the interim dean of the Honors
College, which will
benefit us greatly,
and of course, many
of our students.
And last year, he
was also honored
by the university by being a
distinguished professor which
is one of the highest
honors that the university
can bestow on its faculty.
So it's my great pleasure to
introduce to you Elliott Cheu.
Thank you very much.
Thanks a lot.
Thank you, everybody.
I guess one of the
problems with working
with the dean-- it's not
really a problem-- is
that sometimes you
tell him things
and they become his first joke.
So, I did work on supersymmetry.
We're now turning our
attention to dark matter.
And I'm [INAUDIBLE]
tell you that earlier.
Also, it's a real
challenge to come
after a 15-year-old prodigy.
And I don't know what--
I have nothing left to say.
So hopefully you'll
hear something.
But actually the other thing
is, being the Interim Dean
of the Honors College-- at
least until they kick me out--
is that we can probably
offer him a place.
And he would be a perfect
example of somebody
who would make a great
fit at the Honors College.
So, as you've seen, we
have a flock of physicists.
That wasn't my term.
But we have a flock
of physicists up here
who have told you
about things like what
physicists do, to black
holes, to gravitational waves.
And today I'll talk to you
about particle physics.
And if you look at
these pictures--
and then the last one you'll
hear next week is Pierre
Meystre, who's somewhere
in the audience here,
who will talk about
quantum physics--
you'll notice something very
striking about all these faces
that you see here.
And yes, you're correct
that four of these people
are theorists and I'm
the lone experimentalist.
So, today's talk
will be about to look
at what we do from the
experimental point of view.
And really, the idea is
that while we have this kind
of ongoing, I would say,
rivalry between the theorists
and the physicists-- and
the experimentalists--
[LAUGHTER]
Sorry.
I swear, that was a slip of the
tongue-- between the theorists
and the experimentalists, we
actually work hand in hand.
And I'll try to
show some of that.
But sometimes the theory
is going to precede what--
theorists will come
up with a theory
and that will
actually drive what
the experimentalists will do.
Sometimes, the experiments
will find something
that the theorists had
no idea even existed.
But what's most interesting,
at least from my point of view,
is that when the theory
and the experiment
come into conflict,
when there's a tension--
whether there's an experiment
that sees something
that the theory doesn't
expect or something,
or the theory expects something
that the experiments don't
see--
that actually leads to some of
these big revolutionary things
that happen.
And so I hope to kind
of bring that out today.
But in particular, what
I'm going to talk about--
whoops.
That went-- sorry.
That is right.
What I'm going to talk
about today is basically
what are we made of, what
holds these things together,
and then, kind of the big
question, what's missing?
And I'll help to give
you an example of that
when we talk about dark energy.
But let me walk
back a little bit
and talk about this thing
called the Standard Model.
And Dr. Dienes did
a really good job
of explaining what
all these dots mean.
Basically, the way
I think about it
is that everything on the
left-hand side, those 12
particles, are what everything
that we know of is made of.
It's the matter.
And Dr. Dienes said
that if we were
to break this down to grammar,
those would be the nouns.
The things on the
right are the forces.
Those are the things that
actually hold everything
together.
So for instance, the
photon is the carrier
of the electromagnetic force.
That's actually the
thing that holds
everything that we're looking--
the stage I'm standing on
is solid because of the
electromagnetic force.
And then we come
to the Higgs-- oh.
And by the way, the
forces are like the verbs.
Remember, he said that we
have nouns and we have verbs.
Well, the Higgs does
two things, actually.
Dr. Dienes said that
it's the adverb.
It modifies these forces.
But actually, it also
does something else.
The Higgs, in addition to
modifying the four forces
that you see on the right,
or creating-- giving rise
to the four forces that
we see, also gives mass
to the matter particles.
So in fact, the
Higgs in some ways
can be thought of as an
adjective or an adverb.
This morning I tried to
Google a word that meant,
what's an adverb
and an adjective.
Couldn't find anything.
So at the breakfast table,
I asked my daughter--
she's going to be
embarrassed, but--
I asked her, so
what is a word that
means that a word can be both
an adjective and an adverb?
And she said, why
do you want to know?
And I said, well, you know,
I'm giving a lecture tonight
and I thought I'd use
that in my lecture.
And she says, well then,
you should have figured that
out a week ago.
Anyway, there we go.
So this model that we
have describes everything
that we know about matter.
That is, this is what
we know about matter.
And it actually is interesting,
because if you look at--
Nobel prizes were given
out first in 1901.
And in the years since
1901, up to very recently,
this is the number
of Nobel prizes
that actually were awarded for
the discovery of that model
that I just showed you.
So about 40 Nobel
prizes were actually
devoted to discovering this.
And that actually
kind of demonstrates
you the significance
of this enterprise
that we were launched upon.
But what I want to talk
about is, in particular,
the one about the
Higgs mechanism.
Because that's the one
that's been most recent.
That's the one that you've
heard about in recent times.
And the Higgs mechanism
started with these three men.
Actually, the
unfortunate thing is
everybody knows it as
the Higgs mechanism.
It's actually, to physicists,
called the Brout Englert Higgs
mechanism, the BEH mechanism.
Unfortunately, all of you know
it just as the Higgs mechanism.
And what they had done was
that they had figured out
a way to actually
talk about both
the electromagnetic
force and the weak force
in a consistent way.
And that way has now become
called the Higgs mechanism.
Interestingly,
Victor Weiskopf said,
"particle physicists are so
desperate these days that they
have to borrow from the new
things coming up in many body
physics-- like BCS--"
which is the theory
of superconductivity--
"and perhaps something
will come of it,"
said Victor Weiskopf in 1960.
Well, what came of it
was the Higgs mechanism.
So they actually were
looking at other theories.
The first paper that
Peter Higgs actually wrote
was sent to the top journal in
Europe called Physics Letters.
And that journal rejected it.
So he turned around
and rewrote it.
And they actually
predicted something
called the Higgs
particle-- resubmitted it
to a journal called
Physics Review Letters.
And Pierre Meystre, who's
going to talk next week,
is the editor of that journal.
And that's the most prestigious
journal, by the way,
in physics in the US.
Actually, I would
almost say in the world.
But that's just me.
It was accepted.
And at the same time, the paper
by Robert Brout and Francois
Englert also was submitted,
just about a couple
of weeks ahead of time.
They were published together.
And what were they looking for?
Well, prior to recently,
what their theory said
was that we should find a
particle called the Higgs
particle.
And up until 2000-- well,
until recently, but at the time
that I started getting
particularly involved
in the LHC, nobody
had found the Higgs.
It's actually interesting.
I was listening to a
lecture by Brian Greene
and he said that when he went
to graduate school in the '80s,
it was so thought that
this Higgs mechanism must
be the theory of
the standard model
that he didn't realize that
nobody had actually found
the Higgs particle when
he was a graduate student
for many, many months, until
after he had been there,
somebody said, oh by
the way, you know,
that thing hasn't
been found yet.
And he then realized that it
was an ongoing experiment.
So what I want to do now is
talk about, how do we get there?
So in my world, you
have to do an experiment
and you have to do two things.
The first thing is you have
to find a source of particles.
You have to be able to
create this Higgs particle.
And we do that by
accelerating particles.
Now the next part
of it is that you
have to then be able to detect
those particles-- find out
what you actually found.
And I'm going to kind of
walk you through a little bit
about the history of how
we went about doing that.
The very first particles
that we found--
so, as I talk about these
accelerating particles--
are particles--
oh, sorry.
What we actually
have to do, though,
is we have to produce a
particle like the Higgs.
And in order to do that, you
can't just create a Higgs.
You have to provide a
mechanism to do that.
So what we do is we take
particle A and particle B
and we collide them together.
And if you provide
those two particles
A and B with enough energy,
what they will do is sometimes,
they'll produce a particle
C. And that particle C--
So this equation that you
see on the left-hand side,
E equals mc squared, is that
famous Einstein equation.
And what it really says is that
energy and mass are equivalent.
They're the same thing.
So if you want to produce a
particle of a particular mass,
if you provide enough
energy, that particle
will mysteriously
just pop out of air.
And so the interesting
thing is that in order
to do that, to produce a
particle with a given mass,
you have to provide
enough energy.
But the mass of the particle
that you can produce,
the energy is divided
by that C squared.
So C is the speed of light.
Remember last week, or two weeks
ago, when Sam Gralla talked
about the speed of light--
it's a big number.
So if you square it, it's
an even bigger number.
I don't know what it is.
But it's a really big number.
So in order to
produce a particle,
you have to provide
enough energy in the two
particles A and B to
produce that particle C. So,
how do we do that?
Well the earliest experiments
were done by using cosmic rays.
What you see here is a picture
of the Aurora Borealis, which
is the result of the solar wind
and then other cosmic particles
being funneled by the
Earth's magnetic field
to the north and south pole.
And when those particles
hit the atmosphere,
they produce other particles.
And some of those
particles are light.
And that's why you get
these pretty colors.
But in doing that, you
can actually provide--
you can have a very high energy
particle hitting the atmosphere
and producing another particle.
The problem with
using the cosmic ray--
the flux of particles that
are hitting the Earth's
atmosphere-- is that you don't
know where they're going to be.
And it turns out it doesn't
happen that frequently.
It's about on the order
of, like, one per second
or something like that.
So while it happens, if you
want to accumulate a billion
of these things, you're going
to wait a very long time.
So the next mechanism
was to actually build
something that actually produces
a set of energetic particles.
And Lawrence here was one
of the first inventors
to actually produce
something called a cyclotron.
The way the cyclotron
works is that you
inject in the very
center here a particle
which doesn't have
very much energy.
And when a particle moves
in a magnetic field,
it goes in a circular direction.
It moves in a circular path.
So as the particle gets
ejected from the center,
there's a high voltage supply
which accelerates that particle
just a little bit.
And so as the particle
goes across this gap--
each side is called a dee--
as it crosses that gap,
the particle gains a
little bit of energy.
As it gains energy,
its momentum increases.
And when that momentum
increases, its curvature--
the path it's tracing--
gets a little bit less.
So instead of being
a small circle,
it gets a bigger circle.
So what happens is
that the particles
start at that position A
and wind their way outward.
And each time they
cross that gap,
they get a little
bit more energy.
So at the very end,
they exit the apparatus
with a very high energy.
And so that's a
very neat apparatus.
The only problem with
an apparatus like this
is it requires a magnet
at the top and the bottom.
So if you want to make a bigger
apparatus, in other words, one
that can have more and
more accelerations,
you have to have a
bigger and bigger magnet.
And at some point, you just
can't make a magnet that big.
His very first apparatus
was limited by the size.
And it could produce
a particle that
had an energy of five
million electron volts.
Five million sounds
like a big number.
The number we're going
to be talking about
is hundreds of billions
of electron volts.
So we're talking about
sizes that are not
reachable with this technology.
So the next
technology-- well, OK.
So then, there's
one problem that you
have to get high energies.
The other thing you have
to do is get high rates.
In the 1950s, Frederick
Reines and Clyde Cowan
wanted to try to look for
this elusive particle called
the neutrino, which had
been postulated by Wolfgang
Pauli in the 1930s, when
he noticed that there
was this weird structure
in something called
the beta decays.
And what it caused him
to do was postulate
a particle that didn't exist
and nobody had ever seen.
And not only was it not
seen, but it would be
almost impossible to measure.
Because a single neutrino, if
it went through a certain amount
of lead, would have to
go through a light year
worth of lead before it would
interact with that lead.
OK.
That kind of sounds
impossible, right?
We can't even make things
that are longer than a mile.
So a light year is--
I mean, that's a long distance.
The astronomers can
tell you what that is.
But I know it's a long distance.
So instead of having a
light year worth of lead,
the other thing
you can do is have
lots and lots of neutrinos.
Because eventually, if
you get tons of them--
not tons-- but if you get lots
of neutrinos, some of them
will interact in your detector.
And that's what
he decided to do.
So he decided, well, if I want
to get a lot of neutrinos,
what am I going to do?
And his answer was to
find an atomic bomb.
So you might say, well,
that's not a good reason.
But it turns out, in the 50s,
of course people were exploding
bombs all over the place.
And that was his source.
He actually wrote a
proposal where he said,
I'd like to use an atomic
bomb to search for neutrinos.
Well, it actually was accepted.
But he then realized, after
a few more calculations,
that there's a better
way to do that.
And he went to a
nuclear reactor.
This is the Savannah
River reactor,
where he could sit
outside the reactor
and look for a
source of neutrinos.
If you turn off the reactor,
the source should go away.
And eventually, he actually
discovered the neutrino.
And when he did, he sent a
telegram to Wolfgang Pauli--
now this is 20-some-odd
years later--
saying, we found the
neutrino and in fact, it
does take a light year of
lead to have one interact.
The only problem
with a reactor is
that the particles that
are produced from it
go off in all directions.
So you'd like to
have something that
has both high rate,
high energy, and that
comes to the next progression,
which is called a synchrotron.
And this is the
design for things
that we now use, pretty
much all over the world.
This is the design of
current day accelerators.
The big point of
this is that rather
than having a big magnet
sitting in the center,
you can actually locate those
magnets around the ring.
Because they only have to
direct the particles path where
the particles are.
You don't have to create a
magnetic field in the center
because nothing's there.
So the idea was that if
you can put the magnets
around the ring,
you can actually
make a ring as big as you want.
And that's what's
actually happened.
So in the 1970s,
a ring was built
at the SLAC accelerating center,
which is outside of Stanford.
I actually got to work there.
I was very privileged.
And that ring had a
circumference of 250 meters.
That's pretty large.
This machine, as well as one
at Brookhaven National Lab,
was the one that actually
discovered the existence
of the charm quark.
What you'll notice is that
the mass of that charm quark
is about one billion
electron volts.
So in order to get
energies that you
can produce particles
of very high masses,
you have to get to
a bigger machine.
The next machine is called CSER.
And that was located
at Cornell University.
Actually, this is kind
of a-- seems like it's
a TripTik of my school years.
But that wasn't the point.
The point was that this is the
next probably big synchrotron
that was built. It
has a circumference
of almost a kilometer.
And you can see that the
particle that it was studying,
the bottom quark, had an energy
of four billion electron volts.
And finally, we come
to the Tevatron.
Now this one has a
circumference of six kilometers,
almost seven kilometers.
And this is where the
top quark was discovered.
Now, notice the difference
between the energies.
In the bottom quark, the energy
is 4 billion electron volts.
The mass of the top quark is
170 billion electron volts.
And that's why you need
such a big machine.
OK.
So now, I'm going to
talk about the detectors.
So we've talked
about how you get
from a very small device, where
actually just the cosmic rays
background, to what
we are now doing,
which is looking at
how do we figure out
what those particles are.
So the story starts with
a very simple device.
In the top right, you see a
device called an electroscope.
An electroscope is actually--
you see them in physics labs.
If you ever take
a course from me,
where we do electricity and
magnetism, we'll often--
they don't work with
very well with me.
But you take a
detector, and it just
has two gold leaves
in the middle.
And if you put a charge on
the electrode at the top,
that charge is distributed
on both gold leaves and they
separate.
And so you know that
there's some charge there.
Well, people when they
first made these things soon
figured out that if an ionizing
particle goes through that,
you actually create free
electrons that can move around
inside the electroscope.
And those can hit the gold
foil and cause the charge
to dissipate away.
And so it provides a pathway.
So what you can do with such a
thing as an electroscope is you
can actually take
it to various places
and look for the amount
of ionizing radiation.
In fact, you could do
it in your basement
if you were looking for radon.
You could just take one of these
things, put it in the basement,
and eventually you would notice
that the charge dissipates
away, partly because of the
ionizing radiation that's
going through it.
So he said, well,
it's interesting
that there is this
ionizing radiation.
Where is it coming from?
And so there are two--
well, there are
more possibilities,
but the two thoughts
that he had is one,
it's coming from the
ground, something
is radioactive in the ground,
or it's coming from the sky.
So his idea was to take it
to the bottom of the Eiffel
Tower--
and the tallest building at
the time, in the early 1900s,
was the Eiffel Tower.
It's about 300 meters or
about 1,000 feet tall--
and go to the top of it and
see what's the difference.
If he went higher, the air would
tend to absorb that ionizing
radiation.
And so as he went higher, he
should see that the ionization
rate should go down.
And in fact, that's
actually what he saw.
As he was at the bottom
of the Eiffel Tower,
the ionizing
radiation was higher
and the rate that the
gold leaves went together
was much quicker.
When he went to the top, they
dissipated much more slowly.
And that was actually one
of the first evidences
that there actually are--
well, one, that there's actually
radiation from the earth.
But the interesting
thing about it
was that when he went higher
up, the rate of ionization
didn't go down as
quickly as he thought.
It went down to about a half.
And if he had gone to the top--
I don't remember
that exact number--
but it should have gone
down to like a quarter
or something like that.
So that was saying-- well,
that was a little puzzling.
Because it said that
not only was there
something radiating
from the ground,
but there also
might be something
radiating from the earth.
The next experiments,
actually, Victor Hess
took the same type of
electroscope in a balloon.
And as he got higher
and higher up, in fact
he found that the rate
of ionizing radiation
went up, not down.
And that's because the
Earth's atmosphere protects us
from a lot of that
ionizing radiation.
OK.
So the next thing
I'm going to show
is what you've probably
seen a lot of times before.
When we look at particle
interactions, often what we see
is these funny little
tracks appearing.
And I have a little movie
that's going to play.
And this is called
a cloud chamber.
A cloud chamber is
basically a device that's
filled with a highly ionized--
superheated liquid.
And when particles go
through that liquid,
they actually ionize the gas.
And it causes little
tracks to appear.
So you'll see one here.
We'll wait a couple seconds.
These bright white tracks--
there's one on the right there.
Those are actually
cosmic rays that
are just going through--
they're hitting us right now.
And they're going
through this detector
and leaving tracks behind.
So if you take a
picture of that,
you'll often see something
that looks like this.
Now, as a physicist, we
want to use these tracks
to do something with it.
We don't just want to
take pretty pictures.
They are kind of pretty.
And what we do is we
notice that-- you'll
see that there are two
particles that seem
to come from the same place.
We call that a vertex.
And I have overlaid
on top of that-- there
is a vertex going out with
two particles coming out.
But before it gets there--
I'll just come back--
notice that there's
nothing that leads up to it.
So what that means is that
there's a-- in this case--
a neutral particle which doesn't
interact with my detector.
And all I detect is
the two particles
that come from its decay.
So a neutral particle came in.
It decayed and left behind
two other particles.
The cool thing
about that is that--
that particle's
called a lambda--
when the lambda
comes in and decays,
it leaves behind two
extra particles--
a proton and a pion.
And that's what we observe.
If you remember from
Keith Dienes' lecture,
in physics there are some really
cool and important things.
And those are conservation laws.
In this case, we
can take advantage
of conservation of energy
and conservation of momentum.
And because of that,
these two particles
together have the net
momentum and energy
of the original particle.
So if we can look at the
tracks of what's left behind,
we can actually figure
out what caused that.
So we don't actually have
to see the initial particle.
We can just look at
what's left behind.
Those are what we often call
the daughter or decay particles.
And so if we can measure the
tracks of those two remaining
particles, we can actually
tell what happened before that
and know, even though
it's an unseen particle,
that we have a new particle,
which may be the Higgs,
for instance.
So what can we do with
those two particles?
Well, with those two
particles, as they
go through our detector, they
leave behind these tracks.
You saw them in
the cloud chamber.
In this case, the
tracks, if they're put
inside a magnetic field, curve.
We can measure that
curvature very easily.
And from that curvature, you
can determine its momentum.
Later, as you look at the
particles as they swirl around
and lose energy, the number
of dots in that picture
changes, or the density
of dots along the track.
And if we can
measure that density,
we can then figure out what
the energy of that particle is.
And with those two things--
the energy of the particle
and the momentum--
we can add them
together to determine
what the energy and momentum
of the original particle was.
And that's very important.
We'll come back to
that in a second.
But I just want to leave
you with that one point,
that if you can
determine the energy
and momentum of the
daughter particles,
you know the energy and
the momentum of the parent
particle.
And that's the thing
we're trying to find.
OK.
So the types of technology
that people have used
are these imaging technologies.
And these are kind of the
things that-- you can tell just
from the fact that they're
black and white that these
are kind of older technologies.
On the left is Carl Anderson.
He was one of the inventors
of the cloud chamber
that we saw those pictures of.
On the right is
another gentleman.
I forget his name.
But what he has is just
basically a piece of film.
And that film, if you just leave
it out on top of a mountaintop,
eventually you'll sometimes
see particles that
actually go through and decay.
And there's an example
of a particle that
hit and actually
splattered and created
a whole set of new particles.
So those were
imaging technologies.
Those imaging technologies
are great because you
can see all the tracks.
You get precise information
of where the track is.
You can measure to
infinite precision.
The problem is that
you have to measure
it to infinite precision.
Because these poor women
here-- and they were mostly
women-- were called
human scanners.
They are actually given
a number of pictures
and they had to measure
every single dot along that--
to look through something like
that on the left-hand side
and determine what happened.
And as you can see on that,
by the late '60s, the amount
of data they produced was so
much that three days of data to
took these human scanners
two years to go through
that data set.
Well, that's a problem.
Well, not for me.
But for these people, anyway.
So the next exercise was, how
can we replace this imaging
technology with another
technology which
can measure where the particles
are, but doesn't require us to,
as a human, go through and
look for every single hit
or whatever that is.
And what I'm showing
you here is an example
from Ernest
Rutherford's lab, where
he was the person who
discovered the existence
of the nucleus of the atom.
And you can see here his words.
He said-- what he
did was, he took
alpha particles-- alpha
particles are really
just helium atoms
without the electrons.
They fired them at a
piece of gold foil.
And miraculously, some
of those alpha particles
actually bounced backwards.
And in general, most
of them went forward
because they missed the nucleus.
But every so often, they
would hit the nucleus,
bounce backwards, and you'd
see particles ending up
in the back.
And as you can
see, his quote was
that it was as if you
had fired a Naval ship
shell, a 15-inch shell at
a piece of tissue paper
and it came bouncing
back to you.
I mean, that's how
extraordinary it was.
Well, it's so
extraordinary that he
decided he didn't want
to do the experiment.
He actually assigned it as an
undergraduate research project
to a student at Manchester.
And that was his project.
And the reason it was so tedious
is that to do this experiment,
they actually had to look
at a fluorescent screen
and stare at it with a
microscope in a completely
dark room.
So it took them 30 minutes
to acclimate their eyes.
And after they had been looking
at this screen for a minute,
they had to change out.
So you can imagine
both the human bias
that can be introduced and
also the pain on your eyes.
I don't know how good their
eyes were at the end of it.
But the point is that
this was an apparatus--
they discovered this.
They discovered-- he was
actually-- along with--
so Ernest Rutherford
is on the right.
And on the left is Hans Geiger,
a name you'll come to see.
And they realized this was a
very interesting measurement,
but this is probably not
the way to measure it.
So Hans Geiger actually came
up with something that's
now called the Geiger tube.
This is a device in which
there's a wire going down
the middle of the tube.
And the tube itself
is filled with gas.
When a particle goes
through, it ionizes the gas
and releases electrons.
And those electrons can
travel to the anode,
the wire in the center, and
creates a little bit of pulse.
So you can actually measure
this using a machine now,
as opposed to looking
at it with human eyes.
And you've probably
heard this if you've ever
seen old movies where they
have a Geiger counter.
You turn it on and the
thing starts clicking away.
So that's kind of the next
evolution in technology.
Nowadays, we can take
all those technologies
and put them together.
So now, when we come
to the 21st century,
you can put a bunch of Geiger
tubes on top of each other,
as you can see here.
They're actually called
proportional tubes.
They're operated
slightly differently.
But you can stack them together.
And when a particle
goes through,
you can actually
see the particle
hitting specific tubes.
And from that, you can measure
where the particle went.
You can actually
measure the pathway.
On the left-hand
side, the top left,
is a silicon chip, which
actually has very, very
fine gold wires etched on it.
And those etchings allow us
to actually do the same thing.
When a particle goes
through that silicon chip,
we can actually measure where
the particle went through,
to within a few microns.
It's amazing.
And a micron, if you know,
is a millionth of a meter.
And then finally,
instead of actually
having to try to look at
the density of bubbles
along that pathway,
we can use a device
like the one on the left.
It's called a calorimeter,
just like the word calorie.
It just measures energy.
So we can take this device
here, and by watching
a particle enter and create
a shower of new particles,
we can actually
measure the energy.
So with these
three technologies,
we can now enter
the digital age.
And we now have a device which
we can hook up to a computer
and read the information out.
We don't have to depend
on those human scanners.
And that's what we do now.
So we're now entering
the age of the LHC.
This is a picture
of the LHC tunnel.
So Keith Dienes talked about it.
This is currently the
world's largest synchrotron
that's ever been built.
And what you're seeing is you're
looking down the tunnel of it.
In fact, it looks
like it's straight.
It's so big that you can barely
see that the tunnel curves
a little bit to your right.
Inside the tunnel are these big
blue objects which are magnets.
And those are the
magnets that are slightly
steering the particles
as they try to go around
this very large tunnel.
And this is actually a
picture with actually an image
superimposed on top of it.
So they make a little
bit of a cut away.
And the two tubes that
you see on the center
are actually two tubes which
are filled with protons.
So in the LHC, we
have protons going
one way, which are going
to collide with protons
going the opposite direction.
And when they collide in
the center of the detector,
they can actually produce
some of these new particles
we're looking at.
This device was
very interesting.
Most accelerators up
until this time actually
used a particle and
its antiparticle.
If a particle and antiparticle
are in the same magnetic field,
they'll bend in
opposite directions.
But if the particle
and antiparticle
are in the same tube going
in opposite directions,
they'll bend the same way.
So most accelerators
up to that time
used particles and antiparticles
and put them in the same tube.
Here what we use
is both protons.
Protons both have
the same charge.
So you'll see there
are two tubes.
So these magnets actually have
a very unique configuration
such that you can bend
protons going this way
and protons going that way.
And the way it does it is the
magnetic field on the farthest
tube, say, is pointed upwards.
And the magnetic field on the
inner tube is pointed downward.
So by these very unique
magnets, we actually
are able to produce the LHC.
But before we go
there, I just want
to kind of give you a little
bit of history of where we went.
Dr. Ruiz mentioned the
fact that in the late '80s
and the early '90s, there
was this grandiose idea
to build this thing called the
Superconducting Super Collider,
the SSC.
And the work on this, actually
construction began in 1991.
About that time, the
University of Arizona
created something
called a decision
package, which actually built
up the particle physics group.
And actually the reason
that I'm here today
is because the state
of Arizona invested
in the idea of having a particle
physics group here that could
take advantage of this device.
Unfortunately, unlike Sam
[INAUDIBLE] said with regard
to the LIGO experiment,
this experiment started out
costing--
it was costed I
think at $2 billion.
The cost rose to $4 billion.
And by the time they
canceled it in 1993,
it had ballooned to $12 billion.
So that's a number that
I guess got a little bit
hard to swallow at the time.
So, what did we do?
Well, we decided, well,
what else is around?
So we decided we
would go to Europe.
And so we have joined
this experiment
called the Large Hadron
Collider, or the LHC.
And this is an amazing device.
It's 27 kilometers
in circumference.
It's actually on the border
of France and Switzerland.
It actually crosses the
border-- the yellow line
is the border-- it actually
crosses it four times.
There are no interdictions.
It just keeps going unimpeded.
Anyway, I'll stop there.
And it traverses the
whole countryside.
Our experiment-- there are
actually four experiments.
There's CMS, ATLAS,
LHCb and ALICE.
The two ones that were involved
with the discovery of the Higgs
particle were CMS and ATLAS.
But since we're on ATLAS
we'll just focus on that one.
But I did want to kind of
point out some of the really
interesting things.
When this tunnel
was built, it was
the largest civil
construction project
before the Chunnel was built. So
that's a fairly amazing thing.
It was so big that when they
were digging access tunnels
to get down to where
the tunnel had to be,
they had to actually
freeze the ground around it
so they wouldn't
disturb the groundwater.
And then they sunk
concrete around that.
Once the concrete hardened,
they let the ground thaw
and they didn't have to
worry about the groundwater.
But when they were
sinking the tunnels,
they actually had to do that.
And in addition,
the tunnel is so big
that it's actually tilted up
towards the Jura mountains,
which are towards that way.
You can-- that way.
And the reason that
it's done that--
so it's about 1.4 degrees tilt--
the reason it's done that
is because it turns out
that the rock that they
wanted to drill through
was more conducive to
drilling at that point.
And what it actually did
was it raised the LHC
from being a few
meters underground
to just about 100
all the way through.
The other thing that's
really cool to me
is that when it rains, the
tunnel actually gets bigger.
And that's amazing because--
they actually had a
different apparatus in there.
And that apparatus had to
account for the rainfall
because they could actually
see the energy of the particles
colliding change when
it rained, and also
when it was a full moon.
So both the tidal
affects and the rain
had an impact just on the size.
I mean, that's pretty amazing.
So I said, you have to
have the accelerator.
The accelerator that
we use is the LHC.
The detector we use
is the ATLAS detector.
And I was told I can't walk
outside this white line.
So I'm going to do it.
But this is a person
inside the detector.
This detector is
six stories tall
and it's the size of
half a football field.
So it's actually
quite amazingly large.
And the rate of data
that it has to deal with
is about a billion
collisions per second.
Just to give you
some other numbers,
there are a hundred
million signals
that come out of this device.
That's maybe not so large.
But when you think of where they
have to come to into one place,
that's a lot.
And the amount of data that
we actually write to tape--
so this is actually
going to tape.
This is not the amount of
data produced by the detector.
The detector produces more data
and then we look at the data
as it's coming off the detector
and decide whether or not
to keep it or not.
And so we only take--
I think it was 1
out of 100,000 or 1
out 10,000-- one out of a very
large number of the events
actually are written to tape.
Most of them actually end
up on the computer floor.
And this is what those
pictures have become.
Remember we had
these cloud chamber
pictures of ghostly particles
that would kind of appear
in the detector.
This picture is a transversed
view of the detector.
So if you think of the
ATLAS detector as a big can,
the two protons collide
down the axis of that can.
And at the very
center of it-- so
in the center of this picture--
is where the protons collide.
And then they produce
other particles.
One of them could be the Higgs.
This is actually an example
of a Higgs decaying into two
electrons and two muons.
The two muons are
indicated by the red.
And the electrons are
those green towers
that you kind of see there.
You can see it maybe a
little bit better here.
What's interesting
about this picture
is that there's a lot more going
on than just the Higgs, right?
The Higgs is happening way over
here on the left-hand side.
And all the stuff that's
happening in the middle,
all those other squares--
I don't know if you can see
them, the colored squares--
are actually other interactions
from protons that are also
happening inside the detector.
So one of the things that we
have to do is look at not only
the Higgs decay, but all the
other stuff that's produced
at the same time, and figure
out which of them are Higgs
particles and which ones aren't.
And that's what we have to
do as an experimental group.
And so you can see
this environment
that our experiment
is embedded in
is actually a very challenging
environment to work in.
I do want to say one more
thing about the ATLAS detector.
So in 1993, they
canceled the SSC.
Throughout the US
physics community,
it was actually quite
a shocking time.
People were kind of worried,
what are we going to do?
But my colleagues
were smart enough--
this is John Rutherford and
Mike Shupe they were actually
at CERN at the time,
testing their detector,
which was going to
go into the SSC.
And they walked
across the cafeteria,
found the spokespeople for the
ATLAS detector, and said, hey,
we've got a detector.
Maybe we can put it
into your device--
or, our device
into your detector.
And the original design
of the ATLAS detector
has these two big red globs,
which you can see circled
on this diagram.
And what Mike Shupe
and John Rutherford
did was they said, if
you take our device,
we can put those devices
well inside the detector.
And if you do that,
you'll find that--
and they did tons
of simulations--
you'll find that the detector
actually performs much better.
That the amount of
extra junk that's
produced by having those
detectors outside the detector
will be going way down.
They actually showed that
with a lot of simulations.
And it's true.
It actually did
reduce the background.
And that design was accepted
by the ATLAS management
and was the only US
group to actually
have a significant impact on the
design of the detector itself.
And so in some sense,
I owe my career
to my colleagues, who
were able to demonstrate
that their choice of
detector and design
would have a significant
impact on the ATLAS detector.
And they did that.
OK.
And this is that group there.
It's a relatively
small group of people.
And this is the detector
that they actually
ended up building.
We built it in the basement
of the physics building, which
is just a few-- a block
or so over from here.
And they shipped it to Europe.
And it's been installed
and working great.
OK.
So, when we look at
what-- before we turned
on this the LHC,
this is what-- they
did an informal poll
at Fermilab and asked
all the scientists
there, what do
you think we're going to see?
Well, you can see
there's no consensus.
There's kind of a wide
variety of things.
Obviously, the Higgs
kind of rolls to the top,
but it wasn't everybody's
preferred direction.
And if you're a mathematician,
you might try to add these up.
You'll realize it adds up to
a number bigger than 100%.
People were allowed
to vote twice.
And even then, you can see there
was no consensus about what
they would see.
And my favorite, supersymmetry,
was way down there on the list.
Remember that when
you take the daughter
particles of this particle
like the Higgs and decays,
you can measure its
momentum and its energy.
Well, with those two
quantities, it turns out--
and I'll show you how
in a few seconds--
you can actually
reconstruct the mass
of the particle that produced
those daughter particles.
And so what I'm going
to show you here
is a plot of the mass of every
particle in the ATLAS detector
that decayed to two photons.
And we started
taking data in 2010.
The data taking took
about two years before we
could say anything definitive.
And so what you're
going to look for--
we'll see again-- is that you're
going to look to see whether
or not, as we're
taking data, you
can see any sort
of anomaly or bump
in the distribution of
reconstructed masses
for this Higgs.
And this is what-- oops.
That did not work.
OK.
So this is what happened.
You can see at the very
top, you'll see the dates.
2011, not too much
going on there.
There's a red line
to guide your eye.
2012, we're taking
more and more data.
And all of a sudden, you start
to see something appearing.
And right about July
12, the experiment
decided that we had enough
data to claim that we actually
saw something.
And what you can
see here-- there's
a blue line showing
what you would have seen
if there was no Higgs particle.
And on top of that,
you can see the data,
which is the black dots.
And you'll see that there's
a little bit of a hump.
And that is the
evidence for the Higgs.
And on July 12,
there was a party.
We always have a party.
The man all the way on the
left is Francois Englert,
one of the originators
of this BEH theory.
The person next to
him is Peter Higgs.
Unfortunately, Brout
had died already,
so he didn't get to live this.
Remember that these guys came
up with the theory in 1960.
This is now 2012, so
over 50 years ago,
after their original thing.
The person on the very right is
the director general of CERN.
I can't remember who the
guy is in the middle.
And this was amazing.
Well, it was amazing
for two reasons.
One, Higgs and Englert
had never met each other.
This is the very first
time they met each other,
when they discover the Higgs.
That's kind of cool.
But the other thing
that it did was it
allowed us to actually
say, yes, after 60 years,
we've had this theory
which everybody thinks
is the theory of how the
standard model works,
and now we actually have
proof that it exists.
It took us over 50 years to
figure out that this was right.
So even though the theorists
had this idea-- and they were,
you know, it wasn't
widely accepted,
but people started to
really believe it was true--
it still took us 50 years.
Because we had to have
the right technology,
we had to have the right
group of physicists,
and we had to have the right
environment, someone that
would actually
fund a machine that
would cost billions of dollars
and yet would produce this.
So I did want to say one
thing about these bump-hunting
experiments.
That's what we
call them, really.
So remember that you have
daughter particles that
come out.
We can measure their
energies and their momentum.
Well, with this very simple
equation-- it's not that hard--
you can take the energies,
add them up, square them,
take the momentum, add
those up, square them,
and subtract the two, and
the square root of that--
right, you can put it
into your calculator.
You don't need a spreadsheet.
You can actually just
do it on a calculator--
gives you the mass
of the particle that
produced those two particles,
and there, produces a bump.
So if you see that bump, just by
doing a little bit of algebra,
you can actually prove to
yourself that you've actually
produced this Higgs particle.
This is the paper that
actually resulted from that.
This is the ATLAS paper.
You'll notice a couple things.
It says observation.
That's a very important word.
It means we actually
saw something.
If you saw just a search, it
means you didn't see anything.
So observation in the search
for this Higgs boson--
it's a long title, but
basically it said we found it.
And the paper ran to 29 pages.
And 10 to them were
every single author who
contributed to the experiment.
There are actually almost
3,000 authors and about,
almost 180 institutions.
However, the
University of Arizona
was seventh in the
list of institutions.
And we had 11 authors
on that paper.
So, where are we with this?
Well, in this chart of
everything that we said--
maybe nothing, something
unexpected, supersymmetry--
my favorite--
extra dimensions, so far we're
left with the Higgs boson.
Nothing else so far.
And to some people,
that's actually a problem.
Supersymmetry really was
one of the high theories
that people thought
would explain
the next bit of everything,
including possibly dark matter.
But we're kind of left
with a bit of a conundrum.
So where do we go from here?
Well-- oh.
Before I do that, I just wanted
to mention that in physics, you
might not be able to--
yeah, actually, you
can't read any of these.
But these are nine of the papers
that I've had over my career.
And I just wanted to point
them out, because as I said,
there are some key words
when you read papers.
When you read the title, the
first thing you'll look for
is search.
Search means you
didn't see anything.
And all the blue
ones were searches.
We didn't see a thing.
The white ones were papers where
we actually measured something.
And that's very typical
in particle physics.
Actually, most the time,
we measure nothing.
I would say, probably no more
than 20% of the papers that
have my name on them--
and it's a lot--
did we actually see anything.
All the rest of the time,
we have that word, search.
Now, you might say, OK,
well, he's just a failure.
20-- he's only batting 200.
But actually, that's not true.
The thing is that when one--
oops, sorry.
Hyperactive thumb.
When one measures
nothing, you actually
are telling people something.
One thing you've done
is you've told people,
oh, we've already explored
this area of physics space
and we don't see anything.
That's important because the
next people who come along do
want to know that you
already looked there.
If you looked there and
you didn't see anything,
they shouldn't
have to look there.
And the other thing
is that you informed
the physicist-- the theorists--
that their theory's wrong.
That's actually important, too.
I mean, not because we can just
kind of rub it in their face,
but because it's
important that they
know that that particular
theory they came up with
was not the one that actually
is the way the world works.
And so, even though you
might say I'm not batting
particularly well, we do always
publish even those results
where we don't see anything.
And in fact, as you
can see later on,
the majority of papers
since I've been at the LHC
have been nothing,
nothing, nothing, nothing.
No supersymmetry.
So where do we go from here?
Well, the data that
we've taken, you
can see we measure them
in these funny units--
the amount of data we
measure in this unit
called an inverse
femtobarn, or fb minus 1.
All you have to know is that
as that number gets bigger,
we have more data.
So the green line
shows the data that we
took when we first turned
on the experiment in 2011.
We actually took quite a
bit of data for the time.
In 2012, that number grew
to 22 of those units.
And in 2016, which
we've just finished,
we've even gotten
more data than that.
Well, our plans are to,
by 2023, which is not that
far away, to have almost
100 times more data than we
have now.
And currently, my group and the
other faculty members a U of A
are working on upgrading
the detector so we
can take even more data
up to another factor 10,
or 100 times more data than
we currently have on tape.
So that's what
we're trying to do.
And in order to do that, we've
been working on these chambers.
In fact, we've been
building-- oops.
Where did it go?
There it is.
We've been building
these electronics boards
to mount on these chambers.
Because we have to increase the
readout rate of the detector
in order to keep up
with the amount of data
that we're taking.
There are 15,000
boards that we're
going to mount on the detector.
So we have to build
and test 15,000 boards
and then go mount
them on the detector.
And that's why we have
graduate students.
No, actually, that's not true.
That's why we have
undergraduate students.
And so-- actually,
that's not really a joke.
We do take our
undergraduates out to CERN.
So it's actually
one of the perks.
And while they do have
to replace the boards,
they also get an
experience of working
on this detector, which is
kind of a once in a lifetime
experience.
So where are we going?
What I've done now is I've
described this thing called
the Standard Model.
The Standard Model
describes everything
in that yellow,
little pie shape--
5% of everything we
know about the universe.
The rest of it, we
know nothing about.
So what I've been
doing with my group is
we've been actually looking
in this purple chart,
Because nobody knows
what to do about-- well,
that's not quite true.
But the lighter blue,
69%, dark energy.
That's a whole
different ball of wax.
But we can do things on
dark matter at the LHC.
And so that's what we're doing.
I'm working with a
bunch of theorists
who have come up with a theory
of a new kind of dark matter
called dynamical
dark matter, which
could be produced at the LHC.
And so one thing I hope
you'll find through this talk
is that the reason
that I think physicists
have been able to advance the
field the way they have is
because there's a really
unique collaboration
between the theorists
and the experimentalists.
You know, the
theorists sometimes
have the right answer.
The experimentalists sometimes
fool them and come up
with something different.
But that collaboration
between the experimentalists
and theorists is what
really provides that impetus
for finding new discoveries.
And so here at the
University of Arizona,
we have a group of
theorists, we have
a group of experimentalists,
and of course, we
have the apparatus.
Thank you very much.